welcome to Android design in action I'm
your host Roman Nurik hey guys my name
is Adam Kush and hi I'm Nicola Jett and
today's episode is about the beautiful
design collection on Google Play and I
think it was about a month or so ago
that we released a collection in Google
Play called the beautiful design
collection for summer 2013 and this is a
collection of 11 apps that highlighted
some of the kind of best of class or I
guess some of the best designed apps on
Google Play so in today's episode we're
gonna look through these different apps
on our tablet here and we're going to
talk about some of the some of the best
kind of design details in each app and
then we'll I think we'll have time to go
through all 11 apps and then we have a
couple of things at the end that will
show as well so with that and any other
intro guys Before we jump in a little
bit about how these apps work I think
the idea behind this collection is that
these applications which you know really
embrace the design guidelines but kind
of also go beyond that and really kind
of you know how that that level above
that adds the polish that makes it a
beautifully designed application
absolutely so let's see so the the
collection from the blog post that we
that we posted about this collection
talks a lot about attention to detail
and it's not really about just kind of
you know getting the 80% of the app or
90% of the app looking great it's really
just adding that final 10% of fit and
finish and polish that again like Nick
said goes above and beyond just
following the guidelines and really kind
of you know stressing that you know that
every single part of the app must be
must be polished and really kind of used
to think about every single flow that
the user would go through and so these
11 apps we found contain some of these
you know masterfully crafted design
details and so that's why these are
chosen obviously this is only 11 apps
there are tons more
apps out there in Google Play this is
just kind of the first set of gifts the
first collection in this set and in this
series you should expect more in the
future in the coming I guess different
seasons since this is just a summer 2013
collection and we also wanted to mention
that very recently the you know there's
some other apps that have been published
and Matias Duarte who's the director of
user experience for Android had this
really long Google+ post that talked
about kind of you know where the
guidelines you know sit in terms of the
design process you know how you should
approach the guidelines what types of
decisions you should be thinking about
where you should introduce it we should
begin introducing branding and
consistency and things like that and so
if you're it while we're on the topic I
guess of the beautiful design collection
which again you know the App Store do
follow the guidelines if they go above
and beyond that while we're on the topic
of this I think that you know this post
really kind of summarizes some of the
Android design teams views on the
guidelines and consistency and where
they fit in so with that should we jump
in with the first app ok so the first
app we're going to look at and so
actually these are the the apps that
we're going to look at today we have
pattern eye on the sky pocket timer
Grand Street Pinterest press lot of peas
press New York Times Expedia Flipboard
and Ted so those are the 11 apps in that
collection so the first of these is
pattern so pattern is is basically an
app that lets you you know look at
different wallpapers and actually these
wallpapers are all pattern tiles hence
the name pattern so they kind of tile
across they're not just you know one big
photo or anything like that but it's
really something that lets you browse
and browse pattern and wallpapers and
set them so we're only looking at a
tablet today one of the key things in
this collection actually Before we jump
in here is that most if not all of these
apps are really kind of responsibly
designed so this is one of the and
meaning you know it works on tablet
works on phone works at 7-inch and so on
and so you know
this app right now is one of the the
best examples of a kind of a very nice
standard responsive design where
basically on a tablet here you see
multiple columns of of patterns or of
wallpapers and on a phone you'd actually
see fewer columns maybe just one column
and two columns in landscape and then
you have your kind of core navigation on
the left you basically can jump in
between or switch between different
sections and then you can you know open
up one of these wallpapers and you know
one of the nice touches is that you know
they have these very subtle animations
here don't let you kind of see more and
actually it also kind of goes into
lights-out mode so you actually fade out
or you dim the the navigation bar and
the status bar in the process now one of
the last things I wanted to mention
about this app and obviously the
responsive design I think for me is one
of the biggest things about it that
makes it so great
one of the last things is that you know
there are subtle little touches here and
there like letting you rotate the
wallpaper set the wallpaper
automatically on a schedule and then
also just kind of the overall fit and
finish it really does feel like you know
it does feel like it looking really
truly Android designed app so overall
just a very solid app it's the first one
in our collection can move on to
Pinterest all right so let's talk a
little bit about Pinterest so for those
of you who are not familiar with
Pinterest it's a social networking app
that sort of revolves around these
virtual pin boards where you can pin up
virtual content I will admit I am NOT a
big Pinterest user myself but that
doesn't mean I can't play with the app
and use the app and see how its
beautifully designed so the first thing
you'll notice and this is kind of
interesting because there's no sort of
standard action bar and of course if
you've listened to any of our shows
we're always talking action bar action
bar action bar but in this case they've
actually gone through sort of almost
like a hybrid between top level tabs
which you may see in an app like say the
people app and the sort of standard
action bar where you have branding only
in the top left and it actually works
nicely because on their website they
have the same design and layout so you
can see here they've still got the set
of standard interaction patterns of
swiping between the
tabs where the middle tab is really sort
of home or browse your stream and the
left tab while it does have a search
icon it's more of a like discover tab or
something like something along those
lines and so that's of the first thing I
want to call out the second thing is
this multi-column layout and that's a
game very similar to their website and
this is really nice because obviously
the the social network revolves heavily
around content so it's very content
forward design and it has the added
advantage that it's also very responsive
it scales very well to different screen
sizes as we mentioned before we couldn't
show you the phone layout today but
you'll see on the phone layout and on
the smaller tablet or portrait layouts
you'll see that it's it reduces the
number of columns nicely there one of
the best things about this really quick
is that you know the the chrome of the
app like the the bar at the top I guess
the action slash tab bar the bar at the
top follows the kind of the the natural
Android interaction model but the
content is very much Pinterest it's very
much kind of Pinterest branded content
almost like the exact layout of the of
the posts it's very much kind of
interesting so that's how they kind of
looked one of the ways in which they let
their brand show and they've also sort
of fused the brand design with the holo
design language so you sort of see the
holo design tabs you sort of see the the
buttons are much flatter than what they
have on their website and other
platforms they have sort of the overflow
down here so they've done a very good
job it's sort of the middle ground
between fusing Android design with their
own brand
I'm just want a little thing on
Pinterest I absolutely love the way as
its loading in a new image it'll take
the average color of the image right
yeah yeah there we go so the kind of
color showing you know will be the
average color of the image once it's
loaded it's a completely unnecessary
detailed that I love it kind of is
delightful yeah it's like one extra
database field right but for for a lot
more value there yep okay so that's
Pinterest we we really like the
Pinterest up pocket Nick you in talk
about pocket yeah absolutely
so pocket hopefully you know is kind of
a
reading the news site so you can save
site sites videos images and so forth
into your pocket and catch up later
and so what when trying to pick what I
wanted to highlight in this application
I initially thought about the responsive
design because like these ever
application we looked at so far this app
responds beautifully to the form factor
the device you're looking at on so on a
phone for example it'll use a list based
navigation when you kind of in a quick
ask a moan and as you get to the larger
devices it breaks out into a grid and
then there's kind of a symmetric grid as
you can see here if you have more
content to be lots of lots of down talk
about not filling it out completely in
fact my favorite detail I think about
this application is the sheer focus on
the reading experience and the
application does a lot of stuff but it
doesn't feel heavy in its kind of user
interface everything seems to get out of
the way in order to let you have the
reading of the best reading experience
so for example the user interface here
the action bar and so forth is all quite
muted so it immediately receives out the
way and if you can start scrolling down
through the article as soon as we were
longer it seems you start scrolling down
the action bar heights and once again we
go into this what we refer to lights-out
mode where the system bar and the
notification bar recede to kind of
slightly dim state so it's all about the
the reading experience but as soon as
you start scrolling back up which kind
of indicates you finish the article for
example and the affordances jump right
back so you know you can check the time
or multitask another app or he's one of
the action bar options so it just gets
out of your way and it just works I love
that focus on the reading experience and
the same thing is true of their kind of
pagination model so you can either read
it in a clip like an endless stream so
you swiping up and down or you can swipe
left and right to change like a
paginating content model and and I love
the fact that there's no you know you
can imagine that one way of implementing
that interface would be some kind of
toggle switch or machinery in order to
do it
but instead of doing that they just
listen to what you try you're trying to
use it so if you scroll vertically then
it'll give you a vertical stream screen
of content and if you scroll
horizontally then it'll just
automatically flip into this pagination
content
so again it just reduces all the
machinery around it and just really
really focuses on getting out of your
way and letting you get to the content
so really really great attention to
detail this up mm-hmm yeah it's I'd say
that it's one of the best kind of in
reading experiences you know if at all
you need to build an app that lets you
kind of read through large chunks of
content a large body copy definitely
look at this up is kind of a shining
example how to do that right yeah it
looks a lot different ones that's filled
out with yeah all right shall we move on
to timer so timer is a very very simple
app it's so timer is basically an app
that it's it's just that it's a timer it
has a couple of features and has
basically the I think it has a stopwatch
does it have a stop lunch I should
remember but it basically has a
countdown timer it's it's just kind of
you know your standard run-of-the-mill
countdown timer but the best thing about
this is is the interactions and the kind
of the little ways in which they
sprinkle kind of Android goodness
so for example you know if you pull down
the shade here I'll Android design in
action is life that's good you'll notice
that the notification is very customized
and they have actions built into the
notifications so without even let's say
I'm just at the home screen here I can
manage my timer right from here so I can
pause and resume it I can see how much
time is remaining and you know I can
obviously end it if I needed to but also
one of my other favorite things about
this was that the the interaction for
creating a timer is very simple and
intuitive so you basically just kind of
drag this thing around and sorry for the
lag here I think our HDMI connection is
laggy but you basically just drag this
around it's very it's very tactile and
and I'm kind of visceral the the feeling
of kind of rotating a dial it almost
hints back to earlier the early days of
kind of a rotary telephone and most so
the interaction model here is is very
nice it's also very simple the last
thing I want to point out is that they
have a couple of themes and while you
know having multiple themes is not a
necessity it's always kind of like a you
know nice extra touch and they also you
basically seen everything so if you
switch from the light blue to the light
orange theme basically everything
becomes orange the action bar tabs the
even the app icon becomes orange so you
can see here kind of their single accent
color changes to kind of fit what the
user prefers so overall very nice simple
app obviously also using responsive
design best practices they have a tablet
version and works in portrait landscape
7 inch 10 inch so just an overall very
solid very simple app that kind of just
gets the job done
I think next we have Grand Street yeah
just what we jump into there one I
actually one last really subtle touch
that I really like about this is and you
can't really see it is that in the
actual rich notification they have that
same circular representation of a time
which actually fills in with the color
of the theme that you chose yeah if you
just do your shorter time and maybe I
get less room yeah I just do we could
probably use this app to make sure we
don't overrun oh okay all right
we're gonna do a grand screen so I can I
said didn't I fail so Green Street for
those of you not familiar with is a is
basically a gadget catalog curated
gadget catalog and the Grand Street team
goes and sort of finds these interesting
gadgets and then reviews them and then
post them up through their app and
through their website and the first
thing you'll notice is it's basically
like a digital magazine I've essentially
converted what the old-school version of
a physical magazine into a digital
magazine and you can see it's instantly
full screen imagery really nice
typography and they've actually gone for
this sort of custom action bar but very
much sticking to the interaction
patterns and the layout the sort of gist
of the regular action bar you can see
they've got their app icon in the top
left a spinner next to that and then
they've left the
the area between that empty and then
they've got the regular set of action
items and overflow on the right there I
think it works really well for sort of
taking the focus off the UI elements and
then bringing the focus to the actual
content of the application so you can
see here they've got these like dots
representing the different pages of the
magazine and then this is one of the
products let's uh let's go into it here
and then they've got this really nice
representation of the actual review and
content so between each of the screens
there's actually these fullscreen images
and around subtle design touch as you
can see here it sort of fades fades in
as you swipe out it can read some
information about the design and then
again see another really nice
full-screen image here and an
interesting thing that we can't actually
show here is that if you go into
portrait mode if there's a slightly
different representation and where you
can view the images at the top of the
screen and then the content below that I
can't show that here because we're on
HDMI and it's kind of hard to rotate
around and then I'm not gonna talk too
much more about this because we're a
long time but for previous items that
they've talked about the sort of non
feature items they have this just sort
of nice clean grid view of items and
again it's multi columns so it scales
very well to different screen sizes and
we can go back and browse all of the
previous items that they'd actually
reviewed in the past and the round
Street team actually a really nice blog
post about the iterations of design they
went through it in order to arrive this
if you check out their blog I'll be cool
interesting you'll have to share that in
the in the comments somehow my favorite
thing about this app is just the the
complete kind of focus on fog weed
imagery and and typography and that
really makes it feel more like a
magazine because you know there's no
Chrome and magazines there's no buttons
you can press in a magazine it's really
all content that you're playing with so
this really feels like them and they
even go to the point of engaging the the
low profile mode so that you really sort
of engaged in the full screen content
yep all right right let's move on to I
in the sky weather Nick do you want to
talk about minds guy yeah okay so my
favorite thing about this application is
the sheer simplicity of it and the way
it represent kind of elegantly shows the
information hierarchy so I think they do
a really really great job of really
picking out the most important
information and then making the flow of
that information really obvious so you
know instantly jumps out at you what the
you know immediate conditions are and
then you can tell by kind of the layout
and so forth what the upcoming dates are
and I think is a very simple application
you mean there's a ton of weather
applications out there but I think this
one in particular is a great job of just
elegantly displaying what you need to
know putting everything within easy
reach once again it's also another
example I think like all of the apps in
this collection of great responsive
design so it'll move from a phone device
you'll have these three major sections
on the Left will be and swipe or tabs
and on the larger device every certain
point they kind of get broken out into
it's a dedicated navigation section and
it kind of rearranges what we kind of
call the macro reflow it rearranges the
major content box in order to use the
space well I also personally love the
the upgrade banner at the bottom it's
not in-your-face you can actually
dismiss it and I think if you just miss
it it shows ads but basically well at
some point I show yeah there it is but
it's basically kind of like an
unobtrusive way to hint that other
features that are available or you know
it's kind of like an upsell but it's an
unobtrusive upsell basically so it's
kind of a nice way of doing yeah I think
whether apps are actually interesting
problem because there's so much
information you can display and it's
actually challenging to sort of get
everything displaying a nice concise
format as Nick Racine
yeah Shree move on yeah
all right 48 that's fine we got plenty
of time guys
all right next let's look at press so
press is an app that when you just go to
the very beginning here press is an app
that is basically your feed reader
formerly it hooked up to Google Reader
so it's basically Google Reader client
it would show you all your different
subscriptions and all the different
articles that you haven't read under
each subscription and now it supports a
variety of different services including
feedly which is what we have hooked up
here but the idea is that is basically a
client for your kind of you know you're
you're reading stuff you're kind of
reading queue it's kind of the I would
call it kind of the pre pocket you know
you look at something here and maybe
you're gonna really later you throw yeah
but um but they do here and the reason
we like this app so much is that it's
just very clean again very minimal it's
all about content you can even look here
the the tabs here on the left and
actually on a phone this would be one
screen here on the left and this would
be kind of the next screen we basically
have tabs here on the left and the the
icons for the tabs are incredibly you
know minimal the filled circle means
that it's unread the outline circle
means it's red and the star just means
it's your start at content so it's kind
of a very very interesting workflow you
basically have your you know step one
you have stuff you haven't read step two
is you know the next evolution of that
stuff you've read and step three stuff
that you really care about you've
starred so the hierarchy there is very
clear so once you jump into a category
and then a fee let's look at the verge
for example actually
yeah the burghers fine oh yeah yeah
let's look at all all subscriptions so
you basically have this very simple
master detail flow on the left will
master detail flow and you can kind of
expand this fully and you have another
very very nice reading view now they're
very the one thing that I love about
this app is that the typography is great
you have lots of different choices for
fonts but their default choice I think
it's source sans by Adobe is looks great
here
the the other thing is that there there
are some variations to the design
guidelines so for example if you long
press you get this kind of you know
embedded contextual actions we generally
prefer doing things a different way but
you know it is one way of doing things
and actually the nice thing about doing
it this way is that it offers an
in-place contextual kind of you know
mark everything above me as red mark
everything below me as red so it's
almost like you have an immediate sense
of what your marking is right and
generally we tend to use a contextual
action bar instead but this is kind of
an alternative and then they have like
you know nice little touches you can
mark something as red here and things
like that so overall it's it's a very
well branded app you'll see that the
highlights throughout are this very kind
of sharp red and the general color
scheme is kind of it's almost like USSR
you know like dark gray and and like
bright red it's almost a little stunt
like not stoic but it's almost like you
know I guess USSR colors but it's it's
kind of cool it gives it a very you know
simple sharp feeling so yeah so that's
press and like we said before it's it is
very much following responsive design
best practices supports tablets phones
you know all sorts of things alright
let's keep going
all right so the next step is New York
Times hopefully familiar New York Times
it's a very well-known newspaper and we
really like this up what they've done
here really is is used to things which
are very sort of central core to the
Android design guidelines is typography
and white space to really sort of show
hierarchy and also make it feel like a
newspaper
so immediately see here the the titles
of each article really jumps out at you
and then it's got sort of the brief
blurb below that and then some imagery
in certain cases so let's have a look at
one of the articles here it's a very
clean layout I also like how to use
white space on the sides here to bring
in the margins to make it a better
reading experience and as sort of
recommended they have this swipe to
navigate between articles and the images
are really really crisp so there they're
serving the right size images for
tablets yep and and then also a great
job here again merging this sort of
brand colors in particular typography
really sort of screams New York Times
like you can kind of look at this and
immediately you're like oh that looks
like the New Times it feels like the New
York Times but it also feels very much
Android very much polar design one quick
thing about typography I wanted to
mention is that in general you can't
just throw any TTF file at Android the
rendering engine you know just because
it may look great on your desktop
machine doesn't mean it will look great
on on Android specifically there you
know some character spacing things that
come up with fonts that aren't optimized
so New York Times is font here's is
specifically optimized for mobile so it
works just great and with androids
native type rendering system now
obviously the focus of New York Times is
on a text on reading on articles but
they also actually have a really nice
photo screen
in the abdomen as Roman was saying like
the images are really crisp really nice
this is on a nexus 10 they engage the
low profile mode here so you can really
just get immersed in these images and
they have a similar screen for four
videos as well all right let's keep
going all right next we have Expedia
Nick we're gonna talk about expedient
yeah it's always a shame we're sharing
this on a tablet because they have quite
different running roads and on their
tablet and a phone
I think the phone's been updated most
recently and it kind of knocked my socks
off but kind of them the aspects of the
Expedia of the show really wanted to
call out the elements of kind of fun and
whimsy which they introduced so if you
can see here they have a loading spinner
which is a like a hotel door hanger and
this is actually response accelerometers
I'm not sure we'll be able to show it
the device side to side is kind of like
swings back and forth to kind of remain
level and things like that all the
animations are super smooth and one of
the things the application does really
really well especially the phone one is
is inspire you so he show users kind of
like imagery like you know to inspire
you about different destinations you
might want to travel to so you can you
know why searching for a hotel or a
flight could be like you know quite a
dry task they actually really introduce
fun elements and inspirational elements
that make the making the color process
much more enjoyable you actually find
yourself I'm really enjoying using the
application yeah it is a shame we can't
show the phone version on the phone
version there's this kind of really
beautiful two tab system where on the
first tab you have this kind of parallax
scrolling list of hotels and flights
kind of like deals that kind of give you
some ideas on where to go and along the
design touches of all this one loading
screen I think where it's like a
airplane window and you can actually
like open yeah if you do a flight search
I think yeah you can play with it kind
of the shade on the on the window joints
yeah so not the entire app is a tablet
optimized but certainly the distal
immediate screen okay so let's let's
move on just take our word for word
check out Expedia on your phone it's
it's really awesome the next step is
Flipboard so I don't think
or needs too much of an introduction but
it's again very simple now to my
stranger tablet screens if you press
which back to the phone mode that's fine
so Flipboard is kind of an interactive
magazine it I guess aggregates
everything from Facebook to Google+ to
to you know tech blogs to news to things
like that and puts it in this kind of
unique UI and as you can see here just
from the beginning it's very you know it
immediately starts interact arts I guess
acting you know it starts you know
zooming in photos panning photos and it
really is immersive you know you open
this and you really feel like you're
getting you know a full view of your
content
so let's actually flip through this page
and actually you'll notice that they
have this kind of unique Flipboard
interaction it's kind of a that's the
same across all their different
platforms I believe that's kind of their
their branding is that is that it's part
of their branding that like kind of that
flip so if we open up one of these items
you'll notice that you know it's still
very much it's very much customize the
UI is again just like some of the other
apps that we talked about it's very much
about the content there's minimal chrome
it kind of recedes fades out of the way
but they are like you know like in the
grand streets case they're using their
visual styling but applying our
interaction design and I guess uy
pattern best practices so they still
have the up button in the top left they
still have the overflow that gives you
kind of additional things they do have
this you know additional option for
navigation there but you know whatever
oh and they do have search in the top
right which is kind of the standard
place to expose search but all
throughout there they're kind of
flipping UI is still is still there and
so it still feels like Flipboard just
kind of customized for Android and then
if you open up one of these one of these
articles you notice that again they they
include kind of large margins on the
sides they they tweak the the font sizes
and and line spacing especially to make
sure that on a tablet things look great
they they don't really have a top action
bar here but they do have kind of like a
split action bar will kind of give them
that and basically all the actions are
available at the bottom right and I'm
with an overflow as you'd expect so yeah
so Flipboard overall you know really
custom visual styling but still
following a lot of our information a lot
really information but interaction
design best practices all right better
get a move-on
as always last is Ted right yeah
all right so Ted hopefully familiar with
it they post up some great free TED
talks to inspire you this app actually
follows on sort of holo design language
quite closely
they've just customized the colors
accordingly to fit it really nicely with
the Ted colors which is just sort of the
white and red the focus purely on
content you see there's just great great
big large video thumbnails
multi-column again scales very well two
different screen sizes you can swipe
between the tabs here between these
three main tabs my talks all talks and
featured I've got these sort of three
larger banner images at the top here to
promote the the featured or latest and
then again once you're viewing the talks
you can swipe between the talks very
nicely here you know it's a great app
I'm hopefully a lot of you have seen it
before there's really not that much more
to say other than that they've done a
really good job merging Ted brand with
with Android holo yeah Saad okay so the
last okay so those are the 11 apps in
the beautiful design collection summer
2013 if you if you just search for
beautiful design 2013 you should find
our blog post announcing it and I think
that it's currently visible in Google
Play if you go to apps and scroll all
the way to the bottom now there's one
more app we wanted to talk about Nick do
you want to talk about timely yes so
this is a new app launched just
yesterday I think which is a alarm and
stopwatch and timer application but I
really look up this up so I think the
one word which I would use to summarizes
app is polish every single thing you do
in this applicator
extremely polished so you know from
right here we can show to this panel on
the right hand side show in the current
time is like the main place on the phone
app this would be the launch screen and
I love the way that as you swipe between
the three major tabs that content always
stays persistent so ever it's kind of
like larger when you're in the center
view or over on the side kind of is a
really fun way to kind of use the extra
space on larger devices and as Romans
kind of swiping around you can see
there's suddenly you know the changes in
the background color and the subtly
moving background image is everything
about this application screams polish so
I think one of the fun being so like
they have a lot of custom items in here
so like the background for example is
very very custom and you can even go
ahead and tweak the colors on that which
is kind of fun so if you go into like
the overflow menu and change themes and
then click on that little thing you have
this really really fun kind of like
color picker that lets you just
completely completely customize this
application to you know whatever color
scheme you want and I really love
looking a finger-touch aquatic level
marketing idea that lets you kind of do
the full customization but if you want
to save it that's an in-app purchase so
I think it's really fun like to
demonstrate its value before I am you
know charging you for that yeah if you
want to show the stopwatch and timer so
for example if you look at the
interaction used for setting a timer
well actually all stopwatch is fine okay
it's that much you guys having too much
fun here so hopefully the frame rate is
picking up here but you have this kind
of like almost like a heartbeat you see
the pulse like moving around the circle
tracking the time as it as it goes up
little details like that you know
they've gone beyond the level of just
having the time ticking up they actually
have this beautiful and interactive
animations if you go to the timer as
well I think very similar to the timer
application we looked at before they
have a very visceral way of setting it
but you know it's beautifully engaging
kind of animations and love the way kind
of like as you go past them the minute
or era one of those it kind of how it
shrinks in and grows and grows out also
one of the coolest things is that you
know the text actually morphs so six
morphs into 5 into 4 and so on so it's I
don't know how they're doing that but
it's really really cool
one thing that I wanted to mention is
that they've actually I think I feel
like they've done a crazy job crazy good
job of styling everything to fit they're
almost like transparent UI so even the
settings right even the settings screen
that you'd expect to be kind of boring
is you know has this kind of immersive
you know interactive I guess an animated
background and all of the controls just
like blended beautifully on top of it so
I mean they've just done an insanely
good job on that yes I've just
animations polish everywhere like that
this app is incredible I
sorry-sorry nice yep
okay all right what's I think that's all
the time we have right okay so I think
that's that's all the time we have for
today thanks again for joining and yeah
just one last reminder if you haven't
seen this collection if you haven't
downloaded and installed some of these
apps definitely make sure to do so just
search for beautiful design in summer
2013 and you'll get there
alright that's a challenge so you
designers out there as Roman said at the
top of the show the plan is to update
this collection periodically and so
we're going to slide pull out some apps
bring in some new apps so this is really
a challenge for your designers out there
this is the goal you want to be aiming
for is to be getting into this
collection and so let's see what you can
do all right all right thanks Aaron
thanks Peter